PERTER GRINSPOON: It's very hard to know what to do as a doctor--
I'd say particularly as a primary care doctor--
when people come in asking for pain medications.
On the one hand, you don't want to not treat someone who's genuinely in pain.
And the other hand, you don't want to give someone
pain medications who's not in pain because then you
add to the black market of opioids.
And the person could take it or sell it.
And someone could overdose on the medication.
So it's a very difficult situation whenever
someone comes in asking for opiates.
I tend to be an awful person to ask for opiates just because I've
suffered from opioid addiction.
And a saying in recovery, which is an age
old saying which is really important, is that you can't bullshit a bullshitter.
And given that I've employed almost all of the tactics
that drug-seeking patients employ to try to get drugs out of their doctor,
I feel like I have a very good radar for picking up and perceiving when patients
are trying to scam me for opiates.
So I feel like I do a good job of that.
But that said, there are a lot of times in the office when it's just
in the gray zone, when I just can't tell whether the patient's in pain
or whether they're trying to scam me.
And then I'm faced with this really unsavory choice--
do I want to go home at night and feel like I was scammed.
Or do I want to go home at night and feel
like I was this cruel doctor that didn't treat someone's pain.
So you just have to decide if you want to err
on the side of giving too many medications
or err on the side of not giving enough medications.
You know, it's interesting, I once so much
didn't want to face this dilemma that I prescribed
Percocet for a patient that was claiming he had back pain and a limp.
But I went to the trouble to follow him out of the office.
And I followed him for like two blocks cause
I was just dying to know whether he stopped
limping when no one was watching him.
And for the first block, he limped.
A block and a half away, he limped.
But by two blocks, miraculously he was cured.
And he completely stopped limping.
And he was walking perfectly.
So I discovered that he was completely lying to me
and scamming me for opiates.
So you really-- it's hard to tell.
And you don't exactly know what to do.
But you want to give people the benefit of the doubt.
But opiate addiction is such that it causes people to be dishonest.
And it affects-- people who are so desperate for the medication
that they'll flat out lie to you to get it.
So they're very convincing because they convince themselves
because they think they do need it.
And they do need it, in some senses, because they're addicted.
So it's just very hard to know what to do.
And the answer to what do we do is that we do our best which isn't very good.
But all we can do is do our best.